marseille david khalifa qui se trouve
toujours au qg de thierry mariani avec
ses soutiens dont qui passe aussi leurs
soirées électorales on imagine
évidemment que la déception elle est
immense là bas ah oui samantha et
thierry mariani qui devrait à s'exprimer
d'une minute à l'autre
il est arrivé sur dans cette salle du
10e arrondissement de marseille un sale
choisi pour le candidat du rassemblement
national pour suivre le second tour de
ces élections régionales et vous le
disiez énorme déception immense coup de
massue pour le candidat puisque selon
les dernières estimations en renaud
muselier
elle sort vainqueur renaud muselier qui
a certainement plus bénéficié du retrait
du candidat à deux gauches gens l'auront
fait lydia et le candidat républicain
qui s'est félicité d'avoir gagné face au
péril de l'extrême droite la logique
d'unité
elle sort vainqueur et a démenti tous
les pronostics selon ses mots écoutez
depuis le premier jour c'est la logique
du rassemblement qui a animé notre bilan
notre équipe notre méthode est notre
projet depuis le premier jour nous
avions sur une majorité sortante qui a
démontré sa force pendant la crise sans
jamais laisser personne sur le bord du
chemin
ce soir cette logique d'unité et
d'efficacité l'a emporté ce soir c'est
notre région qui a gagné vous des
provençaux les alpins et azuréens
vous avez fait un choix fondateurs et
décisif vous avez été scrutés décortiqué
analysé depuis plusieurs mois comme le
futur laboratoire du front national on
nous promettait un destin de cobaye nous
avons opté pour un destin de région
libre nous avons refusé la fatalité
d'une région gouvernée par l'extrême
droite
cette décision nous l'avons prise en
conscience au delà des clivages
politiques
nous avons pris notre destin en main
nous avons pris notre destin en mains en
dehors des appareils politiques
thierry mariani qui devrait arriver un
d'une minute à l'autre à vous le voyez
derrière moi les journalistes sont sur
le qui vive pour observer son arrivée
et écouter son discours à l'issue de ce
second tour des élections régionales je
vous disais beaucoup de déception il
malgré cette défaite qui se dessine de
nombreux militants ont fait le
déplacement ils déplorent la
désorganisation du scrutin et
l'acharnement des autres familles
politiques à l'encontre de thierry
mariani je pense que le gouvernement n'a
pas fait de prévention pour avertir les
français qui avaient une élection en
fait je pense que ça arrange le
gouvernement le fait qu'ils aient une
autre est en fait qu'ils aient une
abstention haute
il est évident que l'abstention c'est
l'ennemi du rassemblement national parce
qu'en fait on s'aperçoit que dans les
élections on gagne comme les élections
européennes c'est quand il ya un regain
en fait de taux de participation
c'est dommage de voter contre quelqu'un
parce que les gens qui ont voté pour
monsieur muselier ils ont voté en partie
contre monsieur mariani est pas pour
monsieur musée et je trouve que ça c'est
dommage
est ce qu'on peut dire en tout cas c'est
que cette soirée marque la fin d'une
campagne éprouvante pour thierry mariani
et un duel extrêmement tendues avec son
adversaire renaud muselier
on le sait la région paca entretient une
relation particulière avec le
rassemblement national puisque en 2015
marion maréchal-le pen avait enregistré
elles aussi des scores record au premier
tour en arrivant en tête avec 40 points
55% des suffrages au premier tour mais
la figure montante du parti n'avait pas
réitérer l'exploit est finalement six
ans plus tard thierry à mariani et bien
emprunte le même chemin le même scénario
se dessine pour le candidat du
rassemblement national et qui était une
pièce maîtresse pour marine le pen en
vue des présidentielles en 2022
car si il avait gagné dans cette région
et bien sûr et sonnait comme un exploit
puisque le parti n'a jamais remporté
deux régions dans son histoire
l enjeu reste tout de même pris
sciemment pour marine le pen en vue de
cette victoire républicaine qui se
dessine est une forme de désaveu mais
encore une fois à prendre avec un
certain recul au vu de l'abstention qui
est estimé à plus de 62% marine le pen
qui condamne par ailleurs une
organisation de scrutin à désastreuses
je suis plus que jamais déterminé à
mettre tout mon aîné
j'y ai ma volonté à réhabiliter la
politique à lui rendre son utilité la
présidentielle apparaît plus que jamais
comme l'élection qui permet de changer
la politique font à deux citations
marine le pen qui est déjà en campagne
présidentielle pour 2022 et je vous le
disais à thierry mariani qui devrait
arriver d'une minute à l'autre pour
s'exprimer à l'issue de ce second tour
des élections régionales la région paca
avec un taux d'abstention à 62 2% une
estimation semble-t-il la moins élevée
de toutes les régions david khalifa vous
revenez vers nous des que thierry
mariani s'exprime